okay let's talk a little bit about
eicosanoids another class of lipids so
eicosanoids are twenty carbon signaling
molecules actually derived from
arachidonic acid which is a twenty
carbon polyunsaturated fatty acid shown
here to the right and so you can see
that there are those four double bonds
there and that fatty acid so that's
actually a record donate and this
specifically those double bonds are at
those specific spots carbons 5 8 11 and
14 where those double bonds start but
yeah it's a 20 carbon molecule and it
gives rise to these 20 carbons signaling
molecules in fact I costs means 20 in
Greek so what's the deal with that cost
anoints well when I think my eicosanoids
I think about short okay so they are
short-range signaling molecules they
exert autocrine or paracrine effects
Auto cringe when my cell kind of has
releases molecules to affect itself and
perricone effects those molecules can
will travel a short distance and infect
nearby cells but there aren't any
endocrine effects right they don't
travel very far pretty short range and
don't travel super long distances okay
also they are short-term there are their
effects are pretty instant right they
have instant actions and they wear off
their effects wear off pretty quickly
also they're short-lived there they are
rapidly degraded and metabolized so
short-range short-term short-lived those
are the kind of things that I kind of
associate eicosanoids with okay also
they act specifically via g-protein
coupled receptors I haven't talked about
them as part of this course quite yet
but I will at some point but uh well
yeah so I costumes are also many of them
in fact most of them are
pro-inflammatory
we'll talk more about that and their
functions later when we talk about
specific icon oils also they're pretty
potent okay there are a small amount of
these eicosanoids cause pretty profound
effects okay now there are some types of
classes and sub
classes that we should be familiar with
so let's bring that up here okay so
there are the prostitutes which is
actually divided up into prostaglandins
or PGs and thromboxanes and there's also
leukotrienes okay which are lt''s
there's also like POC sins resolving any
auxins but I'm not gonna talk about any
of that stuff okay mainly just got to
talk about these three here
prostaglandins thromboxanes and
leukotrienes they're pretty much the
most important ones and I've got an
example of each of these shown here so
this is prostaglandin g2 and this is
thromboxane a2 and this is Luca trying a
for now just some notes on these guys
what their stories are so this little
subscript number here that little number
tells you the number of carbon-carbon
double bonds so you'll notice that in p
GG to my prostaglandins g2 there are two
double bonds there and then an inter on
box and a two there are two double bonds
or two carbon-carbon double bonds I
should say and in Luca trying a four
there's 1 2 3 4 carbon-carbon double
bonds there okay
also prostaglandins were found in the
prostate gland hence their name right
frost
prosthodontics scenes were found in
thrombocytes or platelets okay which are
involved in blood clotting and then
we've also got leukotrienes were found
in leukocytes Luca Luca white blood
cells now another point worth mentioning
is that all cells can actually make out
Kosta nodes except red blood cells okay
so that's other thing worth worth
knowing now at some point we'll talk
about the synthesis
you